So the idea behind the example
we've seen so far,
has been that basically we're
interested in controlling illumination.
We can control illumination
with a camera, and
that will allow us to extract various
types of information from a scene.
So, given a control lights, we can
basically scan or re-light a scene.
Scan to extract 3D information,
re-light to be able to then be able
to generate novel images with
different lighting conditions.
So, one big question now comes up is,
how can we actually do much more
elaborate computer control of light?
In the previous example, we basically
showed how we can use an iPhone display
itself to light a scene or how we can
use LEDs which are computer controlled.
But now we want to actually be able to
do much finer control of the light.
Well, that's where projectors come in,
because projectors can be thought of.
And these days, with projectors
with micrometer devices and
stuff like that, and the high intensity
light that they actually can generate,
can be used as really detailed types
of controllable light sources.
Let's see how we can use them.